hello viewers i am ivy the android
i'd like to share today's dinosaur
forecast
a dinosaur outbreak will soon occur
the
resonance
area have been evacuated and a team of
exo fighters has been dispatched
a vortex warning has been issued
please remain indoors
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i make a sense of this situation
even if you invited the chief registered
two years
all i wanted was to be ibis's top five
ibs latest dinosaur forecasts and exoc
technology we're able to keep human
capital teams to zero
[Music]
xoc development is proceeding under the
guidance of the next jet ai leviathan
meanwhile
is continues to encrypt candidates to
become new exo fighters
humanity's greatest
[Music]
[Music]
another exo fighter recruit right
welcome to ibs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if the will to fight still lingers
within you
then accept my offer
and join me
[Music]
valkyrie
here's my words
ragnarok tears our world asander
all we hoped precious
lies on the brink of
annihilation
become my tool of intervention
and save this world
oh
your efforts to remain undetected are
lacking
reveal yourself
who are you
it is quite beautiful
yeah and uh everything here wants to
kill you kind of way
no i'm a world changer
[Music]
that's why i'm so dangerous
nothing could get in my way
let's finish this
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the current
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
it's
[Music]
oh
i think
[Music]
right
ah
so
[Music]
[Music]
in an endless cycle
fighting
dying
returning
always the same
yet always changing
astra
i'm not alone
not anymore
now i stand
before the endless tower
i climb
as sisyphus did
pushing the boulder upward
no matter how high i climb
the challenge
begins
again
but i fight on
through the infinite
seeking answers
seeking ascension
my release is within this tower
and i will find it
[Music]
is this really what you want
and you are certain that what we are
doing is best for the people of the
kingdom
yes
i suppose it would in a sense
true
yes
it made me wonder
am i still that same person
[Music]
the era of myths gives way to an era of
great turmoil the continent was ravaged
by the devastating war between the
empire and the alliance
however one nation remained unaffected
by the chaos
the kingdom of aletane
ward of the august
looked destined to have its soil stained
with the blood of battle
we've finally been called up we're up
against the empire's main army
we are to eradicate every last imperial
who comes ashore keep focused
come on everyone
[Music]
and now you will die
do you really have such a yearning for
war
i can't comprehend it
[Music]
[Music]
so then
what shall we do now
we're going to retake it
this is our chance while they're all
assembled
we should send our best and crush them
that's right
all the more reason to avoid bloodshed
it also likely means that we're in
danger
i suppose it is the only way for us to
survive
[Music]
you